My friend Sarah has run a small online business out of her living room for 12 years.
It's her whole life; she takes it very, very personally.
Last week, one of her clients sent her a ten-page long scathing email,...
...chopping her down, calling her a scam artist and other vicious personal insults,...
...saying she was going to sue Sarah for everything she's worth,...
...as retribution for a mishandled account.
Devastated, Sarah turned off her computer and cried.
She shut off the phones and closed up shop for the day.
She spent the whole weekend in bed, wondering if she should just give up,...
...thinking maybe every insult in this client's letter was true...
...and she's actually no good at what she does, even after 12 years.
On Sunday, she spent about five hours most of the day...
...carefully addressing every point in this ten-page email.
Then she went through the client's website, learning everything about her...
...and offered all kinds of advice and suggestions, and connections.
Sarah refunded the client's money plus an additional $50...
...with gushing deep apologies...
...for ever having upset someone she was honestly trying to help.
The next day, she called the client to try to talk through the situation with her.
The client cheerfully took her call and said, "Oh! Don't worry about it."
"I wasn't actually that upset. I was just in a bad mood."
"I didn't think anyone would read my email anyway."